YEAH. OKAY WE ARE GOING TO
START, OBVIOUSLY, AS A COMMITTEE
OF OURSELVES HERE. BUT I DON'T
WANT TO KEEP MR. ALANIS WAITING.
YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
TO US AS A COMMITTEE, AND THEN
WE'LL ENTERTAIN MOTIONS AND
WHATNOT LATER WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM. IF THAT'S ALL RIGHT WITH
YOU, YOU CAN COME UP. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BRING YOUR
WITNESSES TO THE FRONT TABLE,
YOU CAN DEFINITELY DO THAT. YEP.
RECOGNIZE A COUPLE OF THESE
FOLKS? WELCOME TO THE SENATE
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE. WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAKING HIS PRESENTATION
AND THEN LEAD WITNESSES. WE WILL
COME TO YOU. YOU'LL EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES TO SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS WITH US. AND THEN WE'LL
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AS WELL.
AND THEN WE'LL SEE WHO ALL IS IN
THE ROOM. WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
DAIS AND THEN CLOSE OUT WITH
YOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GO RIGHT
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES. I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR, STAFF AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ANALYZING
AND WORKING ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. AB 1902 WOULD REQUIRE
PHARMACY DISPENSERS TO PROVIDE
ACCESSIBLE PRESCRIPTION LABELS
TO PATIENTS WHO ARE BLIND OR
HAVE LOW VISION. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES PHARMACY DISPENSERS TO
PROVIDE TRANSLATED LABELS IN
SEVERAL LANGUAGES BESIDES
ENGLISH. THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
HAS ADDED TRANSLATIONS FOR
SPANISH, CHINESE, KOREAN,
RUSSIAN, AND MORE. HOWEVER,
THOSE WHO ARE BLIND STRUGGLE TO
READ THEIR MEDICATION BOTTLES,
WHICH INHIBITS THEIR
INDEPENDENCE AND HAS LED TO MANY
HOSPITAL TRIPS FOR PATIENTS WHO
MIXED UP PRESCRIPTIONS OR MISSED
MISSED DOSED STATES LIKE OREGON,
NEVADA, WASHINGTON AND MINNESOTA
HAVE PASSED SIMILAR BILLS TO
ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY. MANY
PHARMACY CHAINS LIKE CVS,
WALGREENS, RITE AID ARE ALREADY
HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED LABELS
WITH LARGE PRINT, BRAILLE OR
TEXT TO SPEECH TECHNOLOGY. AB
1902 IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
THAT THE BLIND COMMUNITY HAS
ADVOCATED FOR MANY YEARS. I AM
PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TWO
WITNESSES TODAY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND.
TODAY WE HAVE REGINA BRINK AND
JEFF. TOM NICE TO HAVE YOU BOTH
HERE. WHICHEVER ONE OF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO FIRST, GO RIGHT AHEAD
AND WE'LL GIVE YOU A COUPLE
MINUTES, OKAY? THERE YOU GO.
IT'S ON. YOU CAN JUST SPEAK.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU JUST
FINE. MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
JEFF. TOM, DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS, CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND. AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID, TEN YEARS
AGO, THE LEGISLATURE ADDRESSED A
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERN FOR
NON-ENGLISH SPEAKING
CALIFORNIANS BY REQUIRING
PHARMACIES TO PROVIDE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG INFORMATION IN
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES. AB 1902
WOULD PROVIDE SIMILAR
REQUIREMENTS FOR THOSE WITH
PRINT DISABILITIES. MEDICATION
ERRORS ARE A SERIOUS PROBLEM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. TO THESE
ERRORS CAN LEAD TO SERIOUS
ILLNESS AND EVEN DEATH. THIS
PROBLEM IS ESPECIALLY PREVALENT
AMONG PEOPLE WITH PRINT
DISABILITIES. FOR EXAMPLE, THERE
ARE 800,000 CALIFORNIANS WITH
SENIOR CALIFORNIANS WITH VISION
LOSS. THESE ISSUES ALSO APPLY TO
PEOPLE WITH COGNITIVE
DISABILITIES. REYES. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT, THIS
PRESCRIPTION DRUG INFORMATION
CAN HELP MANY, MANY
CALIFORNIANS. THIS BILL WOULD
ENABLE A PERSON WITH A PRINT
DISABILITY UPON REQUEST TO
OBTAIN PRESCRIPTION DRUG
INFORMATION IN A FORMAT THEY CAN
USE. MY OWN WIFE, FOR EXAMPLE,
WHO IS ALSO BLIND. NEARLY ENDED
UP IN THE HOSPITAL DUE TO THE
ABSENCE OF ACCESSIBLE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG INFORMATION.
THE MOST IMPORTANT BENEFIT FOR
THE RECEIPT OF THIS INFORMATION
IS, OF COURSE, THE SAFETY OF
PEOPLE WITH PRINT DISABILITIES.
IN ADDITION, HOWEVER, HAVING
ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION CAN
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
STAYING IN ONE'S OWN HOME AND
RELOCATING TO AN INSTITUTIONAL
SETTING. PUT SIMPLY, THE BILL
WILL ENHANCE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH PRINT
DISABILITIES. THUS, WE URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO ENHANCE THE HEALTH,
SAFETY AND INDEPENDENCE WITH
PEOPLE. FOR PEOPLE WITH PRINT
DISABILITIES BY PASSING AB 1902.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GO AHEAD. WE'LL BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU. THE MIKES
RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU THERE.
OKAY, CHAIR ASHBY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, I'M REGINA BRINK,
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS. AND MOST
OF US TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
ABILITY TO READ LABELS AND
DIRECTIONS. BUT FOR PEOPLE WITH
VISION LOSS, THIS CAN BE A DAILY
STRUGGLE. MOST PEOPLE WITH
VISION LOSS HAVE SOME USABLE,
USABLE SIGHT AND ONLY REQUIRE
LARGE PRINT LABELS AND THAT'S
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
ACCOMMODATION. IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT ONLY ABOUT FIVE PATIENTS
PER YEAR FOR THE AVERAGE
PHARMACY WOULD REQUIRE MORE
EXPENSIVE AUDIO LABELS. MY
HUSBAND, WHO'S ALSO TOTALLY
BLIND, TAKES ABOUT SIX
MEDICATION AND IT TURNS OUT HIS
BLOOD PRESSURE PILLS FILL THE
SAME AS HIS PAIN MEDICINE. CAN
YOU IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
HE GOT THOSE CONFUSED? JENNIFER
SHARED HER STORY WITH US AND I'D
LIKE TO READ IT TO YOU NOW. SHE
SAYS. I WAS RECENTLY PRESCRIBED
STEROIDS AND ANTIBIOTICS, PLUS
INHALERS FOR A LOWER RESPIRATORY
INFECTION. I COULD NOT CONSULT
WITH THE PHARMACY BECAUSE MY
RIDE WAS LEAVING AND I HAD NO
OTHER WAY HOME. AND I HAD NO ONE
AT HOME TO ASSIST ME WITH VISION
, I USED SOME SCANNING SOFTWARE
TO TRY TO READ THE LABEL, AND I
WAS CONFIDENT I WAS SUPPOSED TO
TAKE ONE TABLET PER DAY AFTER IT
SEEMED I'D BEEN TAKING IT FOR AN
AWFULLY LONG TIME. I HAD SOMEONE
ACTUALLY READ IT, AND IT TURNS
OUT I WAS SUPPOSED TO TAKE ONE
TABLET TWICE A DAY, AND I HAD
ALSO CONFUSED MY RESCUE INHALER
WITH MY REGULAR INHALER AS
SENSIBLE LABELS COULD HAVE
RESOLVED MY HEALTH SITUATION
FASTER WITH PROPER DOSE DOSING,
THIS IS ONLY ONE OF THE MANY
STORIES WE HAVE HEARD FROM
PATIENTS WHO ARE BLIND OR HAVE
LOW VISION, AND AS JEFF SAID,
SOME RESULTED IN MORE SERIOUS
OUTCOMES. HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS
OR WORSE. AB 1902 MEANS OUR
STATE WILL BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING LAW, AND IT ALSO MEANS
EQUITY IN HEALTH CARE FOR A
GROWING NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS,
THIS MATTER IS URGENT, SO PLEASE
PASS THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. REGINA, IT'S REALLY NICE TO
HAVE YOU HERE. YES OKAY. GOOD TO
SEE YOU. IT'S SO NICE TO HAVE
YOU. OKAY, SO LET'S SEE. IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO IS
OPPOSES THE BILL, WHO OPPOSES
1902. WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD AND SPEAK, SEEING NO
ONE? ARE THERE FOLKS IN THE ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ME TO IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1902, YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, VANESSA KHN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT
WHITNEY FRANCIS WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY,
JENNIFER ROBLESS WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS, AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY, BOTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WHO IS NOT LEAD TESTIMONY BUT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NO ONE? WE
WILL COME BACK TO THE DÍAS
COLLEAGUES. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? I MOVE
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. BILL IS
MOVED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS? I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
THANK MY WITNESSES. REGINA AND
JEFF, FOR COMING IN AND MAKING
THAT GREAT, BRINGING US INTO
YOUR GUYS'S WORLD AND LETTING US
KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WE
NEED TO DO TO HELP AND BE THERE
AND PROVIDE EQUITY FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE. AND WITH THAT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND THANK YOU ALL. WE
DON'T QUITE HAVE A QUORUM YET.
WE NEED ONE MORE MEMBER. WE WILL
HOLD ON TO SENATOR NELLO'S
MOTION UNTIL WE GET THAT QUORUM.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE BILL.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
HELP YOU OUT, REGINA. GIVE US
JUST ONE SECOND. WE HAVE OUR
SERGEANTS COMING TO HELP YOU.
THANK YOU BOTH AGAIN FOR BEING
HERE. HAVE A GREAT WEEK.
ALL RIGHT. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER AUTHORS, AND WE ARE
LOOKING FOR ONE MORE MEMBER OF
THE BNP COMMITTEE TO GRAB A
QUORUM. SO FOR THOSE IN THE
BUILDING WHO HAVE A BILL IN
FRONT OF US, NOW WOULD BE A
GREAT TIME TO HEAD DOWN FOR
THOSE IN THE BUILDING WHO ARE
ABLE TO JOIN US. WE COULD USE
ONE MORE SENATOR.
ALL RIGHT. GREAT. WE ARE GOING
TO CALL THE ROLL AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. ASHBY HERE. ASHBY HERE.
NGUYEN. ALVARADO. GILL HERE.
ALVARADO. GILL. HERE. ARCHULETA.
HERE. ARCHULETA. HERE. BECKER
BECKER. HERE. BECKER. HERE.
DODD. EGGMAN. GLASER MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. HERE. ANELLO. HERE.
NILO HERE. ROTH. ROTH. HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK OKAY, WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE IMMEDIATE
PAST ITEM FROM SENATOR NEAL'S
MOTION. STILL GOOD. SIR? YES, IT
IS. ALL RIGHT. CAN WE GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE ROLL? THIS IS ON.
THIS IS ON ITEM THREE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALANIS IS AB 1902.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG LABELS, WHICH
WE JUST HEARD. GO AHEAD. MOTION
IS DUE. PASSED A SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY
Ã ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN ALVARADO.
GIL. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER I. DODD EGGMAN.
GLASER. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
NILO. NEAL I. ROTH. ROTH I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK. OKAY.
THAT HAS SEVEN. WE'RE GOING TO
PUT IT ON THE ON HOLD AND WE'LL
COME BACK TO IT. AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW,
COLLEAGUES, IF I HAVE A MOTION,
MOTION, MOTION BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA, LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER ONE, ITEM NUMBER
TWO, AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY AYE. NGUYEN.
ALVARADO. GIL. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. BECKER BECKER. AYE. DODD.
EGGMAN. GLASER. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO. NEAL. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK. OKAY. ALSO SEVEN.
GONNA HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
THAT ONE AS WELL. THAT TAKES US
THROUGH OUR CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND NOW WE'LL BE HOLDING OUT
UNTIL WE GET SOME AUTHORS.
I WILL NOTE FOR COLLEAGUES HERE
THAT ITEM TEN AB 2578 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA HAS BEEN
PULLED FOR TODAY. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GO FOR IT. WELCOME
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU. HAPPY MONDAY. WITNESSES
HERE. YES, YES. GO AHEAD AND
BRING YOUR LEAD WITNESSES UP.
THEY CAN SIT AT THE TABLE. GOOD
MORNING. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WHENEVER YOU'RE READY,
GO AHEAD AND GET US STARTED.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, TODAY I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2262, WHICH WOULD
ENCOURAGE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
ADOPT SMALL BUSINESS UTILIZATION
PLANS TO LEVERAGE LOCAL
CONTRACTING ACTIVITIES TO
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES AND
LOCAL ECONOMIC GROWTH. SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE DEMONSTRATED A
UNIQUE ABILITY TO FILL SPECIFIC
BUSINESS NEEDS, FILL GAPS IN
SUPPLY CHAINS, BRING INNOVATIVE
PRODUCTS AND IDEAS INTO THE
MARKETPLACE, AND HELP AMERICAN
PRODUCTS ENTER GLOBAL MARKETS.
WHILE SMALL BUSINESSES SERVE AS
AN ESSENTIAL FOUNDATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY, THEIR
ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTIONS COULD BE
MORE SIGNIFICANT AND STRENGTHEN
LOCAL ECONOMIES IF THEY HAD
ACCESS TO CITY AND COUNTY
GOVERNMENT PROCUREMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. THE SMALL
BUSINESS UTILIZATION PLANS
PROMOTED UNDER THIS BILL WOULD
INCLUDE A 25% MINIMUM GOAL FOR
SMALL BUSINESS PROCUREMENT
PARTICIPATION, AND INCLUDE LOCAL
PROCUREMENT INCENTIVES, FLEXIBLE
SOLICITATION REQUIREMENTS,
UNBUNDLING OF LARGE CONTRACTS
AND TRAINING FOR LOCAL STAFF TO
IMPLEMENT SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS TO
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SUCCEED.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES GENERAL
AUTHORITY TO THE OFFICE OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE TO
SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENT SMALL
BUSINESS PROCUREMENT ACTIVITIES.
FURTHER THE AB 2262 REQUIRES AN
ANNUAL DATA REQUEST TO HELP THE
STATE LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW TO
SUPPORT THIS CRITICAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TOOL. MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
BE THRILLED TO PARTNER WITH
THEIR LOCAL CITIES AND COUNTIES,
BUT OFTEN DO NOT HAVE THE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO NAVIGATE
THE DIFFERENT PROCESSES IT IS
VITAL THAT WE ENABLE COMPETITION
FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO
THRIVE IN OUR ECONOMY. HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB 2262 ARE
PAT FONG KUSHIDA ON BEHALF OF
THE ASIAN CHAMBER, AND JULIAN
CANETE ON BEHALF OF THE HISPANIC
CHAMBER. GOOD MORNING. HELLO.
WELCOME THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE, THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
AND THE CALIFORNIA AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, I
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
FOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES FOR
AUTHORING AB 2262, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS WORK FOR A
LONG TIME. I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
WORK SINCE 1998, AND INVARIABLY,
YOU KNOW, THE STATE IS FIRST IN
BEST IN CLASS AND FIRST IN CLASS
AROUND ENSURING THAT THERE ARE
CONTRACT OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES AT THE STATE
LEVEL. BUT INVARIABLY, AS WE
STARTED TO DO THIS WORK UP AND
DOWN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN A
LOT OF LOCAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES, WE FIND THAT THERE ARE
A LOT OF, BEST IN CLASS AND I
WOULD ACTUALLY SAY WORST IN
CLASS AND IN SOME CASES NØ SOME
JURISDICTIONS SIMPLY DON'T HAVE
A SMALL BUSINESS UTILIZATION
PROGRAM. AND SO WE FELT VERY
STRONGLY THAT THIS WAS AN
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
TOOL FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND FOR OUR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT CAN REALLY GROW AND PROSPER
IF THEY'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET INTO CONTRACT
OPPORTUNITY. AND I WILL SAY THIS
, I'LL USE MYSELF AS THAT SMALL
BUSINESS. I'VE I RUN A
NONPROFIT. WE'RE A CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. BUT PRIOR TO GETTING
MY FIRST PUBLIC CONTRACT, I WAS
A STAFF OF EIGHT. WE'RE NOW A
STAFF OF 42, AND BECAUSE WE GOT
OUR FIRST CONTRACT, WE'RE ABLE
TO EMPLOY FOLKS. THEY PAY TAXES
IN THEIR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THEY RAISE THEIR FAMILIES IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL. SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES FOR,
AUTHORING THIS. IT'S REALLY NEAR
AND DEAR TO MY HEART. SO THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
ASHBY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
DOING KINETIC CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS MORNING TO
ADDRESS YOU ON WHAT WE FEEL IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. AB 2262 I
WISH TO THANK ASSEMBLYWOMAN, AND
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN CHAMBER AND THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHAMBER, WISH TO THANK
ASSEMBLYWOMAN ELOISE GOMEZ REYES
FOR HER UNWAVERING LEADERSHIP ON
AB 20, 2262 AND ALL THE GOOD
WORK THAT SHE AND HER STAFF HAVE
PUT INTO THE BILL, AS WELL AS,
AB 2262 IS VERY SIMPLY REQUIRES
THE OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE WITHIN GO-BIZ TO
COLLABORATE WITH LOCAL AGENCIES
ON STRATEGIES TO INCREASE, SMALL
BUSINESS PARTICIPATION IN LOCAL
PROCUREMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
AUTHORIZES A LOCAL AGENCY TO
ESTABLISH A SMALL BUSINESS
UTILIZATION PROGRAM TO INCREASE
SMALL BUSINESS PARTICIPATION IN
THOSE PROCUREMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
CITIES, COUNTIES, AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT DISTRICTS CONTRACT
FOR BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN GOODS
AND SERVICES, AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. WE ALL KNOW THAT
PUBLIC MONEY SPENT CLOSER TO
HOME WOULD HAVE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT MULTIPLE MULTIPLIER
EFFECT ON THEIR COMMUNITIES,
ECONOMIC ECOSYSTEM, BUT WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL COMPANIES
CAN COMPETE EFFECTIVELY FOR
THOSE CONTRACTS. AB 2262 MODEL
WOULD ASSIST BUSY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STAFF BY ESTABLISHING
OPTIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
UTILIZATION PROGRAM FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SET STANDARDS
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT
ADDRESSES A RANGE OF COMMON
SMALL BUSINESS PROCUREMENT
CHALLENGES. THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
AND OUR MEMBER CHAMBERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FEEL
STRONGLY THAT LOCAL TAXPAYER
DOLLARS SHOULD BE REINVESTED IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REPRESENT SO THAT
THEIR COMMUNITIES ECONOMIC
ECONOMY GROWS LOCALLY, CREATING
JOBS AND A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR THEIR CITIZENS. LIKE
GEO. 156 WITH INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AND AB 2019, WHICH
ESTABLISHES A MINIMUM 25% SMALL
BUSINESS PARTICIPATION FOR STATE
CONTRACTS, AND RECENTLY AB 1392,
WHICH REQUIRES HOSPITALS WITH
OVER 50 MILLION OPERATING
EXPENSES TO REPORT THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS BUSINESS DIVERSITY
SPEND AND ESTABLISH PLANS FOR
THE INCREASE OF THEIR SPAN. AB
2023 2262 BASICALLY SAYS THE
SAME. YOUR, YOUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEED AND SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IF FOR NO
OTHER REASON TO GROW AND BUILD A
STRONG ECONOMIC AND GREATER TAX
BASE. FOR THESE REASONS, WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS MORNING.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL ASK YOU TO STAY PUT
FOR JUST A SECOND AND WE'LL SEE
IF THERE IS A LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NO ONE WILL
TAKE THE ME TWO TESTIMONY IN
FAVOR. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. CHRIS MCCAULEY ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. ANYBODY ELSE IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION BUT NOT A LEAD
WITNESS? OKAY, GREAT. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS? QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. GO AHEAD. CHACHITA THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD. I THINK IT'S A
GREAT BILL. I'M GOING TO MOVE IT
AT APPROPRIATE TIME. MY QUESTION
IS, HOW CAN WE HELP THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TROUBLE WITH THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE? BECAUSE I CAN
SEE IN THE MINORITY COMMUNITIES
THEY REALLY NEED THE HELP. AND
SOMEONE TO WALK THEM THROUGH THE
SYSTEM TO THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY FIND IN THE COMPUTERS, THE
CHALLENGES THEY FIND ON THE
PHONE, TRYING TO REACH SOMEONE
AT THE OTHER END, AND PUT THAT
BUSINESS PLAN TOGETHER. ARE WE
HELPING THEM IN THAT DIRECTION
AS WELL? I CAN ADDRESS THAT. SO,
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE FEEL GO-BIZ IS THE PERFECT,
PERFECT OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS
PROGRAM TO LAND IS BECAUSE YOU
ALL AND GO-BIZ PROVIDES ROBUST
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AND THAT
NETWORK OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND A LOT OF THOSE CENTERS, ARE
FOCUSED ON ENSURING THAT
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES ARE,
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. SO LANGUAGE IS
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION. SO THE
NETWORK OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS THAT GÒM IS CURRENTLY,
INVESTS IN IS REALLY GOING TO
HELP ON THE GROUND THE KIND OF
BUSINESSES THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. MORE,
SENATOR, YOU'RE EXTREMELY RIGHT.
RIGHT. WE'VE SEEN THAT INCREASE
IN LANGUAGE ACROSS THE STATE,
NOT JUST SPANISH, BUT WHEN YOU
GO INTO THE ASIAN COMMUNITY,
WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE OF A NEED
FOR THERE. AND I THINK, THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY MADE IT LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO HELP THESE
BUSINESSES, WHEN YOU SENT BACK
THE BUDGET TO THE GOVERNOR
SAYING NO CUTS TO THE TAP
PROGRAM, AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY WITHIN THESE
SMALL BUSINESSES, THAT MAYBE
HAVE LANGUAGE BARRIERS. SO WE
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM AND OTHER PROGRAMS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE WE'RE
PROVIDING THAT CAPACITY AND
MAKING OUR BUSINESS MORE
COMPETITIVE IN LANGUAGE AS WELL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. OKAY.
GREAT. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND I HEARD A MOTION IN THERE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE FROM THE OKAY
. SENATOR NILO, I WOULD HAVE
MOVED THE BILL, BUT SENATOR
ARCHULETA BEAT ME TO IT. I GUESS
IT'S THE A VERSUS THE N OR
WHATEVER, I'M CLOSE TO THE CHAIR
. PAT FONG KUSHIDA HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN THESE ACTIVITIES FOR
A LONG TIME HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND IN THE STATE. ALSO, WE'VE
BEEN FRIENDS FOR A VERY LONG
TIME, AND THIS IS CERTAINLY, A
SUPPORTABLE BILL. I WILL SUPPORT
IT. I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION,
THOUGH, AND THAT IS WHAT DOES,
TO THE EXTENT FEASIBLE, MEAN IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE BILL RELATIVE
TO THE 25? I THINK IF WE HAVE
AND I'LL LET MY WITNESSES ALSO
TALK TO THIS, IF WE HAVE A HARD,
FAST PERCENTAGE AND IT CANNOT,
IT'S NOT FEASIBLE, THEN THEY
WOULD BE IN, IN, THEY WOULD NOT
BE COMPLIANT WITH THE BILL. SO I
THINK TO THAT EXTENT, TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT IS FEASIBLE, I
THINK IT WOULD BE PROPER
LANGUAGE IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ELSE THE WITNESSES WOULD LIKE TO
ADD TO THAT, IF I MAY, IT
DEPENDS ON THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION AND IT DEPENDS ON
THE TYPES OF CONTRACTS AND THE
AMOUNT OF CONTRACTS THAT ARE
BROUGHT FORWARD. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT FOR SOME OF THESE
CITIES AND COUNTIES, THIS IS A
FAIRLY NEW PROGRAM, A FAIRLY NEW
CONCEPT TO THEM. AND THE GOAL
SETTING IS GOING TO BE VERY I
THINK, HOW I WOULD SAY IMPORTANT
BASED ON JURISDICTION. AND SO
FOR US, ANYWAY, WE DIDN'T WANT
TO OVER OVERLY SUBSCRIBE THAT
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT
OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
THEIR OWN PRIORITIES IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY WANT TO SPEND ON AND
HOW THEY WANT TO SPEND, AND
FINDING THOSE LOCAL EXPERTS.
RIGHT WE WANT TO GIVE THEM THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO HOME
GROW THEIR OWN BEFORE THEY HAVE
TO GET TO THAT POINT. OKAY. AND
SENATOR, I THINK A LOT OF IT HAS
TO DO ON OUR PART. RIGHT? AND
THIS IS OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
BILL AND ITS SUCCESS ONCE IT
PASSES, IS THAT THERE HAS TO BE
THAT COLLABORATION AND THAT
COOPERATION, NOT NOT JUST WITH
THE STATE AGENCY, BUT ALSO
BETWEEN OUR CHAMBERS ON THE
GROUND, THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
WE'VE SEEN THIS WITH GEO 156.
RIGHT. WE SET A GOAL OF 21%
DIVERSE SPEND. WE ARE NOW AT 42.
AND THAT IS ALL THROUGH
COLLABORATION AND COOPERATION.
BUT REALLY, OUR CHAMBER'S TAKING
THE LEAD AS WELL AS WELL AS OUR
STATE CHAMBERS SAYING, HEY, WE
ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU
GUYS TO REACH THESE GOALS. WE
KNOW FIRST YEAR MAYBE WE WON'T
HIT IT, BUT SECOND YEAR WE'LL
KEEP ON WORKING AT IT. SO AGAIN,
PART OF THAT IS OUR COMMITMENT
AS WELL, TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANKS
FOR THE ANSWER. APPRECIATE IT
ALL RIGHT. GREAT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ASSEMBLYWOMAN?
ENCOURAGING SMALL BUSINESS
UTILIZATION PLANS WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR SMALL BUSINESSES TO
GET ACCESS TO CRITICAL RESOURCES
. REYES. AND I THINK THEY NEED
TO BE PART OF OUR ECONOMY. AND
THIS IS A GREAT STEP. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR ARCHULETA.
AND JUST IN CASE THAT ONE SHOULD
FAIL, A BACKUP MOTION FROM
SENATOR NILO, LET'S GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLE. MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE WHEN I WHEN I ALVARADO. GIL
I ALVARADO. GIL I ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA I BECKER. DODD.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GLASER.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NILO I NILO
I ROTH I ROTH I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK I WILK I. ALL RIGHT,
THAT HAS NINE I VOTES. WE WILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR OUR OTHER
COLLEAGUES WHEN THEY GET HERE.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYWOMAN, AND
THANK YOU TO THESE ESTEEMED
WITNESSES WHO I HOPE ARE RATING
SACRAMENTO AS FIRST IN CLASS FOR
SMALL BUSINESS. YEAH. YOU GUYS
HAVE A GREAT WEEK. ALL RIGHT,
MISS SCHIAVO, I UNDERSTAND YOU
ARE PRESENTING NOT ONLY FOR
YOURSELF, BUT ALSO FOR MISS
BONTA. IS THAT CORRECT? ALL
RIGHT. YOU WANT TO START, YES.
AB 1991 IS FIRST IN FILE. OR DO
YOU WANT TO START WITH HERS?
YES. THAT'S FINE. AND I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE A PLUG FOR AB 2262,
WHICH I AM REQUESTING TO BE A
JOINT AUTHOR OF, AND VERY BIG
SUPPORTER. AS A FORMER SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER. SO HAPPY I GOT
TO SEE THAT GO BEFORE ME, SO ON
TO AB 1991, GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS WAS AND I WANTED.
TO PRESENT AB 1991 FOR THE
AUTHOR TODAY, MIA BONTA, WHO IS
NOT ABLE TO BE HERE. SHE'S
ACCEPTED ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
AND THE ANALYSIS AND THESE
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND ACOG, THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY WILL REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION AS SOON AS THE
AMENDS ARE IN PRINT. CALIFORNIA
FACES A MAJOR SHORTAGE OF HEALTH
WORKERS, AND THE STATE ISN'T
PRODUCING ENOUGH NEW WORKERS TO
MEET FUTURE NEEDS. AND THE
CURRENT HEALTH WORKFORCE FORCE
DOES NOT MATCH THE DIVERSITY OF
THE STATE IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
WORKFORCE SUPPLY AND DIVERSITY
ISSUES, THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ENACTED VARIOUS SCHOLARSHIPS AND
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS THAT
ENCOURAGE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
TO WORK IN UNDERSERVED AREAS IN
EXCHANGE FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE OR LOAN FORGIVENESS.
HOWEVER, WE CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE THE DATA ON HOW LONG THEY
CONTINUE TO WORK IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS AFTER THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE ENDS IS THIS BILL
SIMPLY REQUIRES HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS RENEWING THEIR LICENSE
ONLINE TO PROVIDE THEIR NATIONAL
PROVIDER IDENTIFIER IF THEY HAVE
ONE. ALL OTHER INFORMATION IN
THE RENEWAL SURVEY WILL REMAIN
OPTIONAL. THIS WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION TO DETERMINE HOW
LONG A PROVIDER STAYS IN AN
UNDERSERVED AREA AND ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT THE LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM ARE WORKING
AS INTENDED. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT IS VANESSA CAJINA, WHO
IS WITH PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK. AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, VANESSA
KAHENA WITH CP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK THIS
MORNING. PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1991. THIS BILL
REQUIRES CERTAIN BOARDS
REGULATING HEALING ARTS
LICENSEES OR REGISTRANTS UNDER
DCA TO PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION WITH THE DATA
NECESSARY TO ASSESS WHETHER LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS ARE WORKING
AS THEY WERE INTENDED TO BE.
HCAI ADMINISTERS SEVERAL LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY IN THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE AND ENCOURAGE
PROVIDERS TO SERVE IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS. HOWEVER, OUR
ABILITY TO TRACK DATA ACROSS
LICENSING COMPARED WITH PROGRAMS
INTENDED TO INCREASE DIVERSITY
IN OUR WORKFORCES, LAGGING WITH
LATINO AND BLACK WORKERS,
ESPECIALLY UNDERREPRESENT SAID.
IN THE HEALTH WORKFORCE, AB 1991
WOULD HELP TO IDENTIFY WORKFORCE
SUPPLY AND DIVERSITY PROBLEMS TO
HELP IMPROVE IMPACTS ON HEALTH
ACCESS, QUALITY AND EQUITY FOR
OUR MOST UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. FOR THOSE REASONS,
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA'S LEADERSHIP AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHÁVEZ PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING. ALL RIGHT. ARE THERE
OTHERS HERE IN OPPOSITION? IS
THERE LEAD OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS HERE IN SUPPORT ME
TO TESTIMONY. COME ON. FORWARD
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AARON
BOWEN WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA, JUST TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE FOR WORKING WITH US
COLLABORATIVELY TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND TO CONFIRM THAT WE
WILL BE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
WITH THE ADOPTION OF THESE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM THAT'S NOT A LEAD
WITNESS. GREAT. WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES,
ANY COMMENTS? QUESTIONS ÓRDENES
CONCERNS. SENATOR NILO. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I HAVE A
COMMENT THAT IS KIND OF
INDIRECTLY RELATED, AND THAT IS
THE UNDERREPRESENTATION OF BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE IN THE
PROFESSION, NOT UNIQUE TO THIS
PROFESSION AT ALL. AND I JUST
HAVE TO SAY, AS I HAVE IN
CONNECTION WITH, SOME OF THE
REPARATIONS PROPOSALS, OUR K
THROUGH 12 EDUCATION SYSTEM
COMPLETELY FAILS. BLACK AND
BROWN STUDENTS, ESPECIALLY BLACK
STUDENTS, WHO, ACCORDING TO A
CALMATTERS ARTICLE I READ A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, BLACK
STUDENTS ARE THE LOWEST
PERFORMING COHORT IN THE K
THROUGH 12 SYSTEM, WITH THE ONE
EXCEPTION OF ENGLISH LEARNER
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF INHERENT
ABILITY, OBVIOUSLY. IT'S JUST
THAT OUR K THROUGH 12 SYSTEM IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COMPLETELY FAILS DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS, BUT PARTICULARLY BLACK
AND BROWN STUDENTS, AND
ESPECIALLY BLACK STUDENTS. AND
UNLESS WE FIX THAT, THAT ISN'T
GOING TO ADDRESS THIS SHORTAGE
LONG TERM. THAT'S GOT TO BE
ADDRESSED. SO I WILL STATE THAT
EVERY CHANCE I GET UNTIL I GET
SOME INDICATION THAT OTHERS
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH ME ON
TRYING TO CURE THAT INJUSTICE.
OKAY, SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, DURING A TIME
WHEN OUR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
OFTEN DO NOT COME FROM THE
BACKGROUNDS OF THEIR PATIENTS,
THIS IS SIMPLY A MEASURE TO
ENSURE THAT RESOURCES ARE USED
TO PROVIDE CULTURALLY CONCORDANT
CARE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BELIEVE YOU
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR ROTH.
WE WILL CALL THE ROLE. MOTION IS
DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL I ALVARADO. GIL I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I BECKER.
DODD. EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GLASER.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NILO I NILO
I ROTH ROTH I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK I WILK I. ALL RIGHT, THAT
IS NINE ZERO. WE'LL PUT IT ON
CALL. WAIT FOR OTHER COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, BOTH OF YOU
. MISS SHABO, YOU WANT TO MOVE
ON TO YOUR BILL? YES. THANK YOU.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 2015
TO YOU TODAY. I WANT TO START BY
SAYING I'LL ACCEPT THE ABC
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB 2015 IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO HELP ADDRESS
OUR NURSING SHORTAGE. THE
CURRENT PROCESS OF NURSING
FACILITY APPROVALS FOR SOME
PROGRAMS DEPENDS ON THE NURSE
PROGRAM TO APPLY FOR FACULTY
APPROVAL. ESSENTIALLY, AT THE
POINT WHERE THE CANDIDATE HAS
BEEN PROVIDED AN OFFER LETTER,
ANY HICCUP IN APPROVAL CAN
DERAIL THE APPLICANT'S SEARCH.
AB 2015 FIXES THIS BY MAKING THE
FACULTY APPROVAL PROCESS SIMILAR
TO TEACHING CREDENTIALS. AB 2015
WILL MEAN THAT A NURSE CAN APPLY
DIRECTLY TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING FOR APPROVAL,
MAKING THE CREDENTIAL PORTABLE
INSTEAD OF EACH SCHOOL HAVING TO
SUBMIT AN APPLICATION FOR
FACULTY APPROVAL INDIVIDUALLY.
VÆ. ADDITIONALLY, AB 2015
ESTABLISHES A TEMPORARY APPROVAL
PROCESS WHILE A NURSING PROGRAM
WORKS TO ADDRESS ANY GAPS IN THE
FACULTY QUALIFICATIONS, THESE
CHANGES WILL INCREASE THE RN
TRAINING PIPELINE AND HELP US
TRAIN MORE RNS TO PROVIDE THE
NEEDED CARE FOR PATIENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. JOINING ME IS
MARISSA CLARK, THE CHIEF OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSES, TO
TESTIFY AS WELL. WELCOME. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO AHEAD AND
SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS WITH US.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MARISSA CLARK, ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING HERE AS A
SPONSOR OF AB 2015, THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW THE BOARD TO
STREAMLINE ITS CURRENT FACULTY
APPROVAL PROCESS, FACILITATE
FACULTY MOBILITY, AND REDUCE
SOME OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN ON NURSING PROGRAMS. THE
BILL IS NOT LOOKING TO OVERRIDE
OR SUPERSEDE ANY STATUTORY
EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR NURSING PROGRAMS WHO
DON'T REQUIRE THE BOARD'S
APPROVAL FOR THEIR FACULTY.
INSTEAD, WE ARE SEEKING TO
IMPROVE THE CURRENT PROCESS FOR
THE FACULTY MEMBERS AND THE
PROGRAMS WHO DO STILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH OUR APPROVAL PROCESS BY
TRYING TO MAKE IT LESS
BURDENSOME AND MORE FLEXIBLE FOR
THEM, UNDER THE CURRENT PROCESS,
THE BOARD'S FACULTY APPROVAL IS
TIED TO THE PRE-LICENSURE
PROGRAM, NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
APPLICANT. THIS MEANS THAT WHEN
A FACULTY'S APPROVAL IS
AVAILABLE OR SUBMITTED, IT'S
ONLY AVAILABLE TO THE NURSING
PROGRAM. WHO SUBMITTED THEM TO
THE BOARD. HAVING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS TIED TO THE APPLICANT,
RATHER THAN THE NURSING PROGRAM,
WOULD ALLOW THE BOARD TO PROVIDE
UP FRONT APPROVAL TO THE
PROSPECTIVE FACULTY MEMBER THAT
COULD THEN BE USED AT ANY
NURSING PROGRAM THEY WISH TO
TEACH AT. DOING SO WOULD ALSO
ALLOW NURSING PROGRAMS TO
INSTANTLY VERIFY A PROSPECTIVE
FACULTY'S APPROVAL STATUS. AT
THE SAME TIME, THEY WOULD
ALREADY BE VERIFYING THEIR
ACTIVE RN LICENSE ON THE DCA
LICENSE LOOKUP WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE BOARD TO REMOVE SOME
ONGOING ONEROUS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING SHOULDERED BY THE NURSING
PROGRAMS. OUR MAIN GOAL FOR THIS
BILL IS TO MAKE THE FACULTY POOL
PROCESS MORE EFFICIENT AND LESS
BURDENSOME FOR THOSE THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO IT, AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE MEMBER FOR
AUTHORING IT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD BE LEAD
OPPOSITION TO AB 2015 SEEING NO
ONE? IS THERE ANY ME TOO. IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2015 IN THE ROOM.
SEE BILL OKAY. SEEING NONE, IS
THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM THAT ISN'T LEAD
TESTIMONY? GREAT. COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. WE HAVE A MOTION.
SENATOR NILO. WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN APPROVED AND
UNAPPROVED SCHOOLS? OKAY, SO
EVERY BOARD OF NURSING IN THE
STATE, EVERY STATE HAS A PUBLIC
BOARD OF NURSING, AND PART OF
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY IS TO
PROVIDE APPROVAL TO THE NURSING
PROGRAMS WITHIN THAT STATE. THAT
APPROVAL ESSENTIALLY VERIFIES
THAT THEY ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THAT STATE'S NURSING PRACTICE
ACT, BECAUSE EVERY STATE HAS A
LITTLE BIT OF DIFFERENT RULES
WHEN IT COMES TO EDUCATION,
LICENSURE, SCOPE OF PRACTICE,
DISCIPLINE, AND IT ALSO ENSURES
THAT ANYONE WHO GRADUATES FROM
THAT PROGRAM IS ELIGIBLE TO SIT
FOR THE NCLEX, WHICH IS THE
EXAMINATION THAT YOU TAKE IN
ORDER TO ENTER THE PRACTICE OF
NURSING. SO MOST ALL SCHOOLS ARE
APPROVED. I BELIEVE ALL STATES
MAYBE 1 OR 2, MAY HAVE A
DIFFERENT PROCESS, BUT HAVE SOME
TYPE OF APPROVAL. THERE ISN'T
ALSO ACCREDITATION, WHICH IS A
SEPARATE PROCESS, BUT THE
APPROVAL PROCESS IS JUST A
GOVERNMENT KIND OF ENSURING
COMPLIANCE WITH THE MINIMUM
STATE STANDARDS AROUND NURSING
IN THAT STATE. ARE THERE
UNAPPROVED SCHOOLS THAT ARE ALSO
ACCREDITED, DEPENDING THERE
COULD BE CERTAIN STATE LAWS THAT
ALLOW ACCREDITATION TO SUB IN
FOR APPROVAL. I'M IN CALIFORNIA.
IT DOESN'T. SOME SOME STATES
ALSO REQUIRE ACCREDITATION ON
TOP OF APPROVAL. BUT
ACCREDITATION LOOKS AT AT
SCHOOLS MORE FROM THE NATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE IN THAT THEY ARE
LOOKING AT KIND OF THE BROADER
PROFESSION ITSELF, RIGHT.
NURSING BEST PRACTICES KIND OF
CONSTANT IMPROVEMENT. THEY
AREN'T LOOKING AT THAT STATE
SPECIFIC PUBLIC PROTECTION LAWS
AROUND NURSING IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE,
WHAT ARE THE EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. SO THEY KIND OF GO
HAND IN HAND TOGETHER. THERE IS
SOME OVERLAP FOR SURE, BUT THEY
LOOK FROM TWO DIFFERENT LENSES,
ONE FROM KIND OF MORE OF A
COMPLIANCE PUBLIC PROTECTION AND
ONE FROM A BROADER KIND OF,
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT LIKE GOLD
STAR TYPE OF LENS, IF THAT HELPS
. SO THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING, APPROVED SCHOOLS AND
ALSO, INDIVIDUAL PRACTITIONERS,
NURSES, AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO
GO FURTHER AND ACTUALLY
POTENTIALLY APPROVE, PEOPLE
WITHIN THE SCHOOLS. AND WITH A
SHORTAGE OF NURSES ALREADY, IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL, ALMOST BARRIER, TO
CURING THE SHORTAGE THAT WE HAVE
IN THE PROFESSION TO THE FIRST
PLACE. I THINK, SO THIS IS FOR
NURSE FACULTY TO APPROVE NURSE
FACULTY. RIGHT. AND ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT IS THAT WE NEED
NURSE NURSE FACULTY TEACHING IN
MORE PLACES, RIGHT? MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NURSES TO TAKE
THOSE COURSES. AND SO ONE OF THE
BARRIERS HAS BEEN BECAUSE EACH
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION HAS TO
APPLY FOR THAT FACULTY, THEN
THAT FACULTY IS TIED JUST TO
THAT EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION. SO
IF I'M A NURSE FACULTY AND I GET
APPROVED BY, YOU KNOW,
INSTITUTION A, I CAN'T GO TEACH
AT INSTITUTION B UNLESS THEY
ALSO APPLY FOR ME. SO IT'S
ACTUALLY REMOVING RED TAPE, AND
ALLOWING FOR ME AS THE NURSE
FACULTY TO APPLY DIRECTLY TO THE
BURN AND I CAN TEACH AT
INSTITUTION A AND B AND C AND D,
I CAN TEACH AT ALL OF THEM WITH
JUST ONE APPLICATION TO THE
BURN. SO IT'S ACTUALLY, I THINK,
REMOVING BARRIERS AND REMOVING
RED TAPE AND ALLOWING A LOT MORE
FREEDOM FOR NURSE FACULTY TO
TEACH AT MULTIPLE INSTITUTIONS
AND REMOVING THOSE IS, YOU KNOW,
BURDENSOME PAPERWORK THAT ALL
THESE INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO DO
INDIVIDUALLY JUST FOR ONE NURSE
FACULTY ALONE. RIGHT BUT IT
REQUIRES THAT APPROVAL PROCESS.
IF THE BURN CHOOSES TO BE ABLE
TO PRACTICE AT ANY ONE OF THEM.
ALSO THERE'S RIGHT BUT THERE'S
ALREADY AN APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
NURSE FACULTY. IT ALREADY
EXISTS. SO THIS IS JUST FREEING
IT UP FOR IT TO BE INDIVIDUALLY
TIED TO THE NURSE FACULTY
INSTEAD OF TIED TO THE
INSTITUTION OR THAT NURSE
FACULTY. SO IT'S A PROCESS THAT
ALREADY EXISTS. IT'S NOT A NEW
PROCESS. CURRENTLY, SCHOOLS ARE
ABLE TO HIRE FACULTY OR
DIRECTORS THAT THEY BELIEVE ARE
QUALIFIED, RIGHT. AND THEY STILL
WOULD GET TO DO THAT. THEY
CURRENTLY, UNDER THEY DO GO
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
FACULTY. RIGHT NOW. IT'S
ESTABLISHED IN OUR REGULATIONS.
AND THE REASON WE WANTED THE
BILL IS BECAUSE IT WASN'T CLEAR
TO US, SINCE WE'RE TAKING IT
OUTSIDE OF THE NURSING PROGRAM,
THAT WE HAD STATUTE AUTHORITY TO
CREATE REGULATIONS TO HAVE THIS
SEPARATE PROCESS. BUT THE
MEMBERS CORRECT. THERE'S ALREADY
AN APPROVAL PROCESS IN PLACE. WE
JUST WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
AUTHORITY TO WRITE NEW
REGULATIONS THAT WOULD ALLOW IT
TO BE AN UP FRONT APPROVAL,
RATHER THAN SOMETHING WHERE THE
SCHOOL SUBMITS A FORM TO THE
BOARD, WAITS FOR THE BOARD'S
APPROVAL. THEN THEY GET THE
GREEN LIGHT TO HIRE. IT WOULD
JUST THAT EXACT FORM WOULD BE
SUBMITTED BY THE APPLICANT
THEMSELVES, AND THEY JUST HAVE
IT ON THEIR LICENSE LOOKUP. SO
NILO, JUST REALLY QUICK AT THE
STREAMLINING BILL AND SENATOR
ROTH WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
YOUR QUESTION, SO, CURRENTLY,
YOU'RE SAYING A SCHOOL IS NOT
FREE TO HIRE AN INDIVIDUAL,
FACULTY MEMBER OR DIRECTOR,
IRRESPECTIVE OF ANY REVIEW BY
THE BURN, DEPENDING ON THEIR
ACCREDITATION STATUS, THERE ARE
CERTAIN PROGRAMS, IF THEY HAVE
PROGRAMMATIC ACCREDITATION,
THEY'RE NOT SUBJECT TO IT. BUT
IF THEY DON'T, WE JUST ENSURE
THAT THEY MEET THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS ESTABLISHED IN
LAW FOR FACULTY UNDER THE
NURSING PRACTICE ACT AND THE
REGULATION, AND WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF NURSING SCHOOLS, ARE NOT
ACCREDITED RIGHT NOW. IT'S
AROUND 40% THAT THAT NUMBER
TENDS TO KIND OF GO UP AND DOWN
AS WE HAVE MORE SCHOOLS, START
TO COME IN, BUT IT'S AROUND 40
OR SO PERCENT ARE DON'T HAVE
PROGRAMMATIC ACCREDITATION. AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK AT
IMPROVING THE PROCESS FOR THEM.
OKAY, OKAY. SENATOR ONE OF MY
MAIN CRITICISMS WHY NOT ONE OF
MY MAIN, ONE OF MY CRITICISMS
WHEN I WENT THROUGH THIS PROCESS
, WHEN I WAS HAPPEN TO BE THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE A FEW
YEARS AGO, WAS THE CUMBERSOME
PROCESS OF APPROVING FACULTY,
SCHOOL BY SCHOOL, BY SCHOOL. AND
I THINK THIS BILL IS A VERY GOOD
BILL. IT ADDRESSES THAT
SITUATION. IT STREAMLINES THE
PROCESS. I THINK IT ADDRESSES
EVERY ONE OF MY CONCERNS AT THE
TIME WHEN WE WERE DOING SUNSET
REVIEW HEARINGS, COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR DOING THE BOARD, FOR
DOING THE BILL, AND THE BOARD
FOR PARTICIPATING IN THIS. LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE RESULTS OF
THIS PROCESS, AND I WILL BE
CLEARLY, SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AND I THINK I MOVED IT. SO THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THE BILL IS
MOVED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? OKAY. SENATOR
EGGMAN, JUST TO WEIGH IN IN HERE
FOR A SECOND. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ARCHULETA, THAT AS A FACULTY
PERSON AT A UNIVERSITY, IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO KEEP A NURSING
FACULTY. THEY CAN MAKE MORE ON
THE OUTSIDE. ON THE OUTSIDE. I
MEAN, LIKE, THEY'RE
INSTITUTIONALIZED, BUT,
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION
OR A NURSING SCHOOL CANNOT PAY,
INSTRUCTOR GENERALLY WHAT THEY
ARE COMPETITIVE AT OUT IN THE
MARKET AND SO IT IS MORE
DIFFICULT TO KEEP THEM. SO I CAN
SEE THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO A
MORE, STANDARDIZED SO PEOPLE ARE
ABLE, IF THEY WANT TO TEACH, TO
MOVE INTO DIFFERENT PROGRAMS, TO
TEACH VERSUS JUST HAVING TO DO
OUTSIDE WORK. ALL RIGHT. GO
AHEAD. DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL
RIGHT. YOU HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR ROTH. WE'LL CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. WHEN NØ. ALVARADO. WHEN? NO
ALVARADO. ALVARADO TO. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. DODD. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO.
NILO AYE. ROTH A ROTH AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK AYE.
WILK AYE. OKAY, THAT'S NINE
YESES AND ONE. NO. WE'LL STILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE HAVE A FEW
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. AND WE HAVE JUST
ONE LAST AUTHOR. SO FOR SENATORS
THAT ARE MEMBERS OF THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS CONSENT. OH,
SORRY. WE WE'RE ON OUR LAST
AUTHOR. HE HAS TWO BILLS.
ASSEMBLYMAN, ARE YOU READY? GO
GOOD MORNING. YEAH. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. WHEN YOU ARE
READY, SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. IF WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
2148. YES, BILL ON FIDUCIARY ON
OUR PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES,
WHICH HELPS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES BUREAU
BY HELPING TO ENSURE LICENSURE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND WITH ME TODAY
IS TO PRESENT IN SUPPORT IS MR.
JERRY DESMONDE. GREAT. THANKS
FOR JOINING US. YOU HAVE A
COUPLE OF MINUTES THERE, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, JERRY DESMONDE WITH
THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE AS
CLOSING A LOOPHOLE THAT EXISTS
IN CURRENT LAW. WHEN AN ENTITY
IS APPOINTED AS A GUARDIAN OR
CONSERVATOR OR A PERSONAL
REPRESENTATIVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE ARE CAPTURED BY THE
STATUTES, AND WE REALIZE, AS
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS, THAT
THE CURRENT FIDUCIARY BUREAU IS
UNDER FISCAL CHALLENGE AND
RECENTLY INTRODUCED INCREASED
OUR LICENSURE FEES
SIGNIFICANTLY. BUT WE UNDERSTAND
I THINK IT'S IN SECTION SIX,
FIVE, FOUR FOUR OF THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL THAT THERE
WOULD NEED TO BE FEES TO ADDRESS
WHATEVER THE ENDS UP BEING. THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE BUREAU FOR
THIS POPULATION. AND WITH THAT,
WE HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS AND
URGE, I VOTE ON THE BILL. GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2148
IN THE ROOM? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
FAVOR WHO'D LIKE TO DO ME TWO
TESTIMONY OR OPPOSITION THAT
WOULD LIKE TO DO ME TWO
TESTIMONY? THAT'S IT. THEN WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES?
SENATOR NILO? SURPRISE,
SURPRISE. I'M SURPRISED, I CAN
SEE THE, THE BENEFIT OF THE
BILL. I'LL SAY. BUT I'M
WONDERING, IS THERE SOMETHING.
OH, BY THE WAY, I REALLY LIKED
YOUR FACEBOOK POST ON REGARDING
YOUR FATHER, BROUGHT BACK
MEMORIES MYSELF, WHICH I
INDICATED IN A COMMENT. HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE BILL. BUT
IS DID SOMETHING HAPPEN? WAS
THERE A CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
CREATED THE PERCEIVED NEED FOR
THIS, AS OPPOSED TO THE WAY IT
THE PRACTICE BEEN IN THE PAST?
YES. YES, SENATOR, THERE ARE,
WITHOUT NAMING WHAT
JURISDICTIONS IN WHICH
INDIVIDUALS WE DO HAVE
DOCUMENTATION THAT THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE A COURT HAS
APPOINTED AN ENTITY WITHOUT
NAMING THE SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS
IN THAT ENTITY WHO WOULD BE
ACTING AS FIDUCIARY, AS
CONSERVATORS OR GUARDIANS. AND
WE'RE HOPING TO GET AHEAD OF
THAT. AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR OVERSIGHT AND
RESPONSIBILITY WITH THE WITH THE
ENTITIES BY CLOSING THE
LOOPHOLE. SO WE HOPE THAT WE'RE
BEFORE THERE BEING AN LA TIMES
KIND OF ARTICLES OR IN THE IN
THE PRESS OR SOME PROBLEM THAT'S
ARISEN BECAUSE OF THAT. SO WE'RE
HOPING AHEAD OF THE CURVE. OKAY.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. IS THERE A
MOTION FOR THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT.
MOVED BY SENATOR EGGMAN, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR OUR VOTE. GREAT. WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
ASHBY A ASHBY. AYE. WHEN
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER DODD.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
GLAZER. AYE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
AYE. NILO NILA. AYE. ROTH
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK. AYE.
WILK AYE. SO THAT HAS EIGHT
VOTES. WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL AND
HOLD ON TO IT FOR SOME OF OUR
OTHER COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO YOUR WITNESS FOR BEING
HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MOVE ON TO AB 3119?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES. AB 3119 IS A
CRITICAL STEP TO HELPING IMPROVE
THE LIFE, THE ASSISTANCE OF OUR
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS AND
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF LONG
COVID WITH ME TODAY IS A DEAR
CONSTITUENT. AS SUSANNA
ZARAYSKY, WHO WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SHARE HER STORY AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, FIRST I
WANT TO ASK ALL OF YOU RAISE
YOUR HAND IF YOU REMEMBER HOW
HARD IT WAS TO BUY TOILET PAPER,
HAND SANITIZER AND CLOROX WIPES
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC. OKAY NO ONE'S RAISING
THEIR HANDS, BUT YOU'RE
LAUGHING. SO I THINK YOU ALL
REMEMBER. WELL HERE WE ARE FOUR
YEARS LATER, AND IT'S EVEN
HARDER TO FIND DOCTORS OR OTHER
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHO TREAT
LONG COVID SYMPTOMS, THAN IT WAS
TO GET CLOROX WIPES BACK FOUR
YEARS AGO. I PROPOSE THIS BILL
TO MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER, EVAN
LOWE, BECAUSE MANY MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS LACK THE EXPERTISE
TO TREAT THEIR PATIENTS WHO HAVE
LONG COVID. AND LONG COVID IS A
SET OF MORE THAN 200 SYMPTOMS,
SUCH AS BRAIN FOG, CHRONIC
FATIGUE, LOSS OF SMELL AND
TASTE, MUSCLE PROBLEMS,
RESPIRATORY ISSUES, AND OTHER
ISSUES THAT PEOPLE SUFFER AFTER
THEIR COVID INFECTION. AFTER MY
MILD COVID CASE A YEAR AGO THAT
LASTED ABOUT TWO DAYS, I
RETURNED TO WORK. BUT I COULDN'T
FOCUS IN MEETINGS. I STRUGGLED
TO SPEAK AND I COULD BARELY
ORDER A COFFEE. I HAD FORGOTTEN
BASIC WORDS. I SOMETIMES I
SOUNDED LIKE TARZAN WHEN I WAS
TRYING TO SPEAK. I HAD TO GO ON
DISABILITY LEAVE. MY GENERAL
PRACTITIONER REFERRED ME TO THE
STANFORD LONG COVID CLINIC, BUT
I WAS TOLD TO WAIT FIVE MONTHS
FOR AN APPOINTMENT. FIVE MONTHS?
I WAS DESPERATE AND I REFUSED TO
WAIT THAT LONG TO SEE A DOCTOR.
I WAS SLEEPING 10 TO 11 HOURS A
DAY, AND I STRUGGLED TO GET OUT
OF BED IN THE MORNING. I USED
MOST OF MY ENERGY TO SEARCH
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR MEDICAL
HELP. THERE WAS NO DOCTOR IN THE
BAY AREA WHO WOULD SEE ME. I HAD
TO FIGHT TO GET A TELEHEALTH
APPOINTMENT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WITH THE UC DAVIS LONG COVID
CLINIC. THERE WAS ONE CLINIC IN
LOS ANGELES THAT REQUIRED AN
IN-PERSON VISIT, WHICH WOULD
HAVE REQUIRED AN EIGHT HOUR
DRIVE FOR ME, WHICH IS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CHRONIC FATIGUE. THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC IMPACT WITH
THIS SCARCITY. LONG WAIT TIMES
FOR APPOINTMENTS MEAN THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO STAY IN
DISABILITY FOR A LONG TIME, AND
SOME PEOPLE LOSE THEIR JOBS, AND
THIS COULD POTENTIALLY BANKRUPT
THE STATE'S DISABILITY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEMS.
AND WORSEN THE BUDGET DEFICIT
THAT ALREADY EXISTS. OVER 400
MILLION PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD
HAVE LONG COVID JUST LIKE ME,
AND MANY ARE SUFFERING IN
SILENCE AT HOME. NEARLY A FIFTH
OF COVID PATIENTS ARE AT RISK OF
DEVELOPING LONG COVID, AND WOMEN
ARE TWICE AS LIKELY AS MEN TO
GET THIS DISEASE. I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES BECAUSE ALL OF YOU HAVE
CONSTITUENTS SUFFERING JUST LIKE
ME. OR EVEN WORSE, WITH EVERY
COVID WAVE THAT WE HAVE, MORE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO NEED LONG
COVID CARE AND WITHOUT THIS
BILL, WE WON'T HAVE ENOUGH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS, PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS AND DOCTORS TRAINED
TO TREAT LONG COVID. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY
WITH US AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION THAT
WOULD CONSIDER THEMSELVES LEAD
OPPOSITION TO 3119 SEEING NO
ONE? IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 3119 THAT WOULD
LIKE TO DO ME TWO TESTIMONY OR
FOLKS WHO ARE OPPOSED TO AB 3119
WHO WOULD LIKE TO DO ME TWO
TESTIMONY, SEEING NO ONE WILL
COME BACK TO THE DÍAS ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES?
ALL RIGHT. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR EGGMAN. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. I JUST
WANT TO THANK SUSANNA FOR
HELPING TO JOIN IN DEMOCRACY IN
ACTION. THIS BILL IS THE
FORMATION OF ACTUALLY A PANCAKE
BREAKFAST IN WHICH WE HOSTED A
TOWN HALL. AND WE SOLICITED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS. AND SUSANNA, IT WAS
VERY COMPELLING AND A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE, AND I WANT TO THANK
HER AND ACKNOWLEDGE FOR THE
ACTIVE CITIZENRY AND JOINING US
HERE IN THE STATE CAPITOL. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
IT'S A GOOD ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
LISTENS TO HIS CONSTITUENTS SO
MUCH THAT YOU FIND YOURSELF HERE
IN A HEARING ROOM, RIGHT, VERY
GOOD. YOU HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR EGGMAN AND WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS THIS
UNDER APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN
NGUYEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. AVARGAL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER
DODD. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR AYE. NILO. NEAL. AYE.
ROTH. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WILK
WILK. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS
NINE VOTES AND NO NO'S. BUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL ANYWAY,
BECAUSE WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
COLLEAGUES STILL OUT. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMAN, AND THANK YOU FOR
TRAVELING TO SACRAMENTO TO SPEAK
WITH US. YES. MORE THAN HAPPY
TO. OKAY. THOSE OF YOU IN THE
ROOM WHO HAVE ALREADY VOTED, YOU
ARE FREE TO GO IF YOU VOTED ON
ALL ITEMS. OTHERWISE, WE ARE
GOING TO ASK FOLKS WHO ARE ON
SENATE B P, E, B AND P TO COME
ON DOWN AND WE ARE GOING TO OPEN
THE ROLL AND HEAR A FEW OF THESE
ITEMS. LET'S GO AHEAD AND OPEN
THE ROLL ON CONSENT. THIS IS
ITEM ONE, TWO AND EIGHT. THIS IS
THE CONSENT. AGAIN IT HAS SEVEN
AYE VOTES AND NO NOS. DO YOU
WANT TO CALL THE ROLL FOR THOSE
IN THE ROOM WHEN I, WHEN I DODD
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. HI.
WILK I ALL RIGHT, THAT ONE HAS
11 VOTES. KEEP IT OPEN. I THINK
WE'LL KEEP THAT ONE OPEN. STILL
ALL RIGHT. AND THEN WE'LL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM THREE. THIS IS
ALANIS PRESCRIPTION DRUG LABELS.
HE HAS SEVEN I VOTES NO NOES
CHAIR VOTING. AYE. VICE CHAIR
WASN'T HERE YET WHEN I, WHEN I
DODD EGGMAN EGGMAN I GLASER
GLASER I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS WILK
HI WILK I ALL RIGHT, THAT'S ALSO
11. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL YES.
CERTAINLY WILL. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THE TWO LOW BILLS. OUT OF
ORDER. FILE ITEM 6AB2148. LOW ON
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES. IT HAS
EIGHT EYE VOTES AND NO, NO
VOTES. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WEN. BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS ALL RIGHT. THAT ONE HAS
TEN EYE VOTES AND NO NOES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON. CALL ONE MORE HERE.
OUT OF ORDER. FILE ITEM SEVEN.
ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AB3119.
THIS IS PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS
SITTING AT NINE EYES AND NO NOS.
BECKER. BECKER I DODD ROTH A,
ROTH I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS ALL
RIGHT. THAT HAS 11 VOTES. WE
WILL GO BACK TO OUR FILE. ROLL
HERE. ORDER FILE ITEM FOR THIS
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. BUT IT
WAS PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHIAVO AB 1991 HAS NINE EYE
VOTES AND NO NOS. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BECKER EYE. BECKER EYE. DODD
LASER. LASER EYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS OKAY, THAT'S 11 EYES. NO
NOS. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL GO
TO SHABBOS BILL THAT SHE
PRESENTED FOR HERSELF A B 2015.
THIS IS FOR NURSING SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. AND FACULTY MEMBERS.
IT HAS NINE EYE VOTES AND ONE NO
VOTE. CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. BECKER, A
BECKER EYE DODD SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS ALL RIGHT. THAT ONE SITS
AT TEN EYES AND ONE NO WILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. YOU'VE DONE
THE LOW BILLS SO WE'LL GO TO THE
REYES WHICH IS FILE ITEM NINE AB
2262. THIS IS HER SMALL BUSINESS
BILL. IT SITS AT NINE EYES AND
NO NOS. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE. BECKER. BECKER EYE.
DODD. GLASER. GLASER. EYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. THAT'S 11
EYES AND NO NOS. WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON CALL. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE, AND
WE'LL GIVE, I THINK WE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE MEMBER OUTSTANDING ON
ON THEIR WAY DOWN. SO WE'LL HOLD
THE ROLL FOR THAT.
OKAY. WE HAVE OUR LAST SENATOR
HERE. LET'S LIFT THE CALLS. GO
THROUGH ONE MORE TIME. HERE
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
CONSENT, WHICH IS FILE ITEMS
ONE, TWO, AND EIGHT. OKAY. DODD.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I ALL RIGHT. FILE ITEM
THREE. ALANIS AB, 1902. OUT. OH,
YEAH. I'M SORRY. THE CONSENT
CALENDARS ARE OUT. ITEMS ARE ALL
OUT. AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM THREE, WHICH IS ALANIS,
1902. DODD. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS I ALL RIGHT,
THAT ONE IS AT 12. ALSO OUT.
FILE ITEM FOUR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA'S AB, 1991 DODD.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I 12. THAT ITEM IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB 2015 BY CHAVO
VOTES 10 TO 1 DODD SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I CUEVAS I THAT'S 11 I'S
ONE NO THAT IS OUT FILE ITEM SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE COUNT
VOTES 10 TO 0. WHEN DODD.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I 11 TO 0. THAT ITEM IS
OUT. FILE ITEM SEVEN. ALSO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LOWE AB 3119
DODD. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I 12 I'S NO.
NOS. THAT ITEM IS OUT. FILE ITEM
NINE BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN REYES.
DODD. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I ALL RIGHT,
12 A'S. NO. NOS. THAT ITEM IS
OUT. THAT'S IT FOR THE SENATE.
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. ALL RIGHT,
I GOTTA RUN.